Michael's with us Michael's in st. Louis
hey Michael how are you I'm doing good
day thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I just finished grad
school I have some debt I picked up some
student loans far from school their
student loans did pick up and then also
have $10,000 $10,000 want to credit card
debt trying to figure out if I should
use money from my previous employer that
hadn't rolled over yet to my parent
employer that I put in 401 if I should
use that to pay down the debt or pay off
a good portion of that debt are or not
come on how much student loan debt do
you have student loan about twenty
thousand and then you got another ten so
you got 30 total correct and your
graduate degrees in what security a
Masters of Science in cybersecurity in
what say again Master of Science in
cyber security cyber security okay good
excellent so you land a big job I have a
job but I'm trying to get into the cyber
security field I'm currently doing IT
work as these systems business analyst
okay and what are you making I make
about seventy five thousand excellent
very good are you single no I'm married
okay I'm my wife she's currently in
school also however how are you paying
for that she's new in student loans okay
um how much student loan debt is she
have oh she probably have a seventy
thousand she's going for PhD great when
does she graduate she graduation by a
year and a half okay how much more do
you need money wise to clear to get her
through with no more student loans uh
probably about another 25 thousand does
she work outside the home other than the
PhD yes she does
what does she make she makes about forty
thousand okay she have a household
income of a hundred and fifteen thousand
the first thing I would tell you to do
is not go any further into debt
and that means paying cash for the
remaining of a portion of her education
which you should be able to do making a
hundred and twenty thousand bucks a year
no more borrowing okay you can't get out
of a hole while you're digging out the
bottom I agree and so stop the borrowing
is the first thing and then the second
thing is is now you're telling me we
have $100,000 in debt here that we've
got to clean up now what will our PhD be
in it's in higher education okay and so
when do you think she'll be generating
an income like associate Oh works now in
addition to in addition to the 40 I mean
okay
I could probably a year and a half and
I'm kind of looking like set for work in
the cybersecurity field as well as again
which could take your income up another
thirty or forty or fifty probably right
you know entry level on that anyway so
okay cool
well here's the thing I just want you
guys to roll up your sleeves and be very
very focused because this is going to
get out of control very quickly if you
don't so step one is no more debt you
cash flow her education
step two is any money we can find in
addition to that we start working the
Total Money Makeover baby steps which is
you're going to save a thousand dollars
in baby step one after you're paying for
you know you go save a thousand bucks a
little starter emergency fund and then
we're gonna start working to pay off
this hundred thousand dollars in debt
and we list our debts smallest to
largest a minimum payments on everything
but the little one and attack the little
one so that little $10,000 debts going
to be the first one that goes away and
then your student loans are going to go
away and then hers are going to go away
unless they're broken up and if they're
broken up into smaller loans and you're
just giving me the totals then list them
out and whichever I don't care whose it
is we're going to pay off smallest to
largest debts and start clearing them as
fast as possible so you're making 115
120 now as she comes out and as you go
up you should get up over 200 and if you
keep your stinking lifestyle down man
you can clean this mess up in a year and
a half two years that's what I'm trying
to do yeah and is she on board with that
yes he is good deal have you
got a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover yet I do not I'm going to give
you one man
so hold on I'll have Kelly pick up
because you guys need this gate this
gives you the framework the the bones of
the system and shows you how to do this
this process that so many people have
used to get out of debt and YouTube the
- you need to read through it and then
you'll understand why I just gave you
the same exact recommendation that I
gave you
hey thanks for listening man we
appreciate you calling in hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show I want
to write a song I want to own my own
business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish